-Imagine Alice traveled back
over 50,000 years to find
her distant ancestor, Bob.
Now up until this time,
human culture was relatively
unsophisticated, utilizing
the same primitive stone
tools which went unchanged
for thousands of years.
But somewhere around
50,000 years ago, something
interesting happened, and nobody
knows for sure why.
There was a sudden explosion
of diverse cultural
artifacts, including
instruments for making music,
new tools, and other forms
of creative expression.
(foreign singing)
-Humans developed the
ability to externalize
their inner thoughts.
They began to communicate using language.
So Alice begins her search
by looking for water.
She knows that human and
animal populations tend to
migrate towards and along rivers which are
the life blood of ecosystems.
Eventually she comes across
an interesting marking,
Bob's hand print.
This marking contains very
little information, simply
that he was here and
could possibly return.
Alice knows Bob is equally
intelligent, he can
communicate orally, although
his culture has not yet
developed the ability to read or write
in their native language.
At the time, the universal
written language was art.
So she finds natural
materials around her to paint
him a picture in case he returns.
She renders an animal
she is tracking, hoping
this will offer a clue
about the direction she
is traveling in the future.
Our ancestors used natural
materials to create
pictorial representations
of their reality.
Here is an actual cave
painting from around
30,000 years ago, found
preserved deep inside
Chauvet cave in France.
Similar renderings are found in
the caves of Spain as well.
A common theme among
these ancient paintings
are animals forms, as
well as the human hand,
perhaps a signature, a
story, or a ritual calling.
-When Bob returns to the
waterfall, he finds her
painting and proceeds
towards the river where he
thinks she might be.
When he arrives, he does not find her,
though he finds a sign
that she was here before.
He decides to paint her a
picture explaining where
he is going next, which
is halfway up the river
towards the setting sun.
He has little time to
paint a picture as night is
approaching, therefore
he needs a fast way to
visualize his message.
He thinks about it for a
moment and realizes his
message only contains three
distinct mental objects,
middle, river, west.
So, he decides to use simplified
pictures to represent them.
For river, he draws a
symbol which resembles
its natural form, known
as a Pictogram, which is
a drawing that resembles the physical
object it represents.
Pictograms are an important step
in the evolution of writing.
Here is a ceremonial slate
palette found in Egypt,
dated before 3,000 BC.
The surrounding scene
shows the struggle between
civilized humans and the
wild and ferocious animals.
However, it's difficult
to draw pictures of
abstract concepts, such
as calm, old, dangerous,
or in Bob's case, middle.
For this, he draws a line
with a box over the middle.
It represents halfway.
This is known as an
Ideogram, or conceptual
picture of an abstract idea.
Here's an example of this
same symbol on an ancient
Chinese bronze inscription.
For the idea of West,
he decides on a picture
of the setting sun.
Now he does something interesting.
He combines these individual
symbols in terms of
their meaning to create a message.
Meaning plus meaning equals new meaning.
He leaves this in hope
of Alice finding it.
-Some of the earliest
artifacts of this symbolic
merging are found in ancient Mesopotamia,
now modern Iraq, home of the Sumerians.
This is the birthplace
of many of the world's
earliest civilizations.
Here we find clay accounting
tablets, which are some
of the oldest written
documents ever found,
some dating before 3,000 BC.
The rectangular tablets
record the payments
in cattle, shipments of
cattle to shepherds for
fattening, and gifts of
cattle as an offering.
Notice that instead of
drawing a picture of 10 sheep,
they draw a symbol
representing 10, using small
notches, and another symbol
representing sheep or
donkey, meaning simply 10 sheep.
We call this Protowriting.
Finally, Alice returns
to the base of the river
and finds Bob's message.
She interprets the meaning correctly,
halfway West, down the river.
So she marches down river
towards the setting sun,
and eventually they finally meet.
-Over time, Bob learns to
speak Alice's language,
allowing them to use the
same oral language to
communicate shared concepts and ideas.
This gives them an
idea, the root of a more
powerful written language.
It starts with something very
simple, writing her name.
She disassociates the
sound from the picture
for her name Alice, Alice, Al-ice.
She combines the
mathematical symbol for all,
and a picture of ice.
All ice.
Al-ice.
Notice her name has nothing to do with the
individual symbols.
Sound plus sound equals new meaning.
This is known as the Rebus principle.
-A great example of
this was found in Egypt
along the Nile River.
Dated to around 3,100 BC,
it contained some of the
earliest hieroglyphic
inscriptions ever found.
The Narmer Palette depicts the Egyptian
pharaoh, Narmer.
On the back we see him
to the left of a kneeling
prisoner who's about the
be struck down by Narmer,
who we see standing tall, wearing a crown.
What we are looking for
is on the other side,
between the two bovine
heads at the top, we see
an inscription of his name.
It's written as a fish and a chisel, which
translates to Nar Mer,
Narmer, two sounds, separated
from the pictures together,
giving new meaning.
A key development in
the history of written
language, but before they
could advance towards
what we know of as an alphabet, something
had to happen.
They needed to save time.